there are big companies being hit by SQL
injections all the time still in 2016
and if you mess it up then all your
usernames and passwords are out there in
Pohnpei spin or what have you and it's
it's it's bad PR not to mention illegal
you know data protection acts and so on
and it's yes bad news for everyone
involved and inevitably bad news for the
hacker as well who probably goes to jail
okay so I should just preface this by
saying that you know if you do this you
will go to jail so really don't you know
I'm doing it on my own website which is
allowed because I've given myself
permission I sometimes go back and watch
older computer file videos because you
know maybe I came to computer for a bit
later because I know maybe I was busy
doing something I don't but the reason
is so I go back and I look at these
videos and the home scott did a
reinserting video on SQL injections
which is exactly right okay so I'm not
going to remit the wheel by talking
about exactly how they work but what I
thought is I do some and perhaps
demonstrate to anyone who's got an
interest in web development just how bad
it is if you mess this up this little
potential I can social product anyone
who actually does web development or any
kind of design will see immediately this
is this is bad okay we've got a lovely
little blue gradient here and a just a
box okay so I can search for hammer and
when I do that I get a couple of hammers
up so I get a claw hammer in a sledge
hammer right and I can search for other
things nails is it I don't know a common
what I'm selling in this hardware shop
yeah okay so different kinds of nails
all right these are all the nails I know
it exists right different different
arbitrary links of nail I assume they
it's elbows anyway all right this is not
a shot that you would actually want to
put your credit card details in this
shop also apart from being bad as a shop
is also bad as a web program because
it's PHP and I haven't escaped strings
like I should have done when I type in
hammer and click submit a post request
goes off PHP receives this and
constructs an SQL query but says you
know give me any roads that have hammer
in and then asks the database for all
those rows and then spit some out on the
screen problem arises is if we put in a
special SQL command character in this
text box then the string but PHP forms
is going to be malformed in some way
it's not going to make any sense as a
query any more or it's going to make
sense as two queries or so on and
bad news for everyone involved the first
thing we do is we work out whether this
text box is vulnerable at all okay so if
you put a single quote in right and we
press submit and it says server error we
apologize for the inconvenience
okay what's very nice of them but this
is that bad news right we're in a proper
server would say there is no product
with name single quote because there
isn't or it will return any products
like by O'Reilly you know hammers you
know that have an actual single quoting
it should have used that single quote as
a character not as a control structure
so what can we do to attack this well
the first thing we need to do is think a
little bit about what the query might be
behind the scene so we can we can adjust
it so I've got my my text editor here
and I'm going through I'm gonna type in
a query so I'm thinking that the query
is going to be something on the lines of
select something right some question
mark from some table I don't know what
the name of it is it could be product or
prod or you know IDs I don't read it
could be anything from some table where
some column is like hammer if I search
for amme which is the middle characters
of hammer I also see that it finds the
hammer which means that is putting
wildcards in either side so that's what
my query is select something from some
table where something is like hammer I
have control over this bit this hammer
word I can't change the rest of a query
because that's back-end PHP code that's
already been coded so where are you
typing this now this is just a text
editor I'm just doing this so my own
head I can visualize the query right you
wouldn't necessarily have to do this if
you were super good at this right but it
helps and also it's obviously
illustrative to people who are watching
also this does SQL markup syntax
highlighting so I can show you how the
query changes as I change it so this is
my generic query right how do I edit it
well what happens if I if I just put in
a single quote so I'm going to copy this
line if I put in a single quote instead
of Hamor
that's what happens now you can see
those few percents of different colors
and the reason is because what's
happened is this first percent is inside
a proper string and now the second
percent sitting on its own outside of
any SQL string and that's going to cause
a server error so that's just that
texture just to shown you by the color
coding that yeah this is showing me
pretty much what would be going on in
PHP when I type single quote into that
into that box which is
that basically breaks SQL because it
sends a malformed query okay that's not
a valid query the server will respond
the database will respondent with an
error and PHP will say server sorry for
the inconvenience so the question then
becomes what do I change this single
quote into to really get information out
of this and the first thing that's
important to do is find out what
database management system is running
this on the server so imagine that SQL
is a language that's shared by a bunch
of different database management systems
so SQL Server MySQL Postgres and so on
so forth they will all have very similar
syntax slightly different but very
similar certainly select will be the
same and the point is that if I know
which one it is
I can then start targeting that one
directly and for example find that where
there lists of table names are finding
the listed table names obviously quite
helpful for me to get rid of some of
these question marks and fill in some
blanks first of all I can get rid of the
rest of this malformed query by putting
in a end of command and the comment okay
and you'll see in this intact if it's
gone gray which tells me but now this is
the query that I'm typing in so if my
input to this shop is single quote then
a semicolon and a comment then what
should happen is it should change to
this query here which is select
something from the table where wildcard
which means everything so I should get
all of the products in the database
which I do ok so this is all the product
it's not very good shop the two dozen I
don't know okay no one wants these
products north buy my things right so so
that's a start now what do we put in as
well to try and break this so the first
thing we can do is we can put in
something that will only work if MySQL
is the database management system now I
could also do an equivalent for Mokpo
stress or equivalent for SQL Server
I happen to know secretly but this is my
SQL but you could automate this pretty
quickly so what I'm going to say is
select something from something from
where something like this thing okay and
I'm going to put in hammer because I
only want to return the two items okay
well that would make sense in a minute
we're hammer and one equals sleep too so
what I'm saying there is find any
products that are called hammer and also
where the function sleep to sleep for
two seconds wait for two seconds
returns a one so that should still
turn to hammers but it should take four
seconds to do so because there's two
hammers alright that's my hypothesis
let's see if it works so I'm going to
copy exactly from hammer all the way to
the end of my quote there and I'm going
to paste that in and we're going to see
and it's thinking it's thinking and it's
taken four seconds it's not found any
products which probably means sleep
return of zero not one so there's my bad
right it doesn't really matter the point
is it weighted exactly four seconds and
then returned us either some products or
not some products so that was basically
you just trying to command just to see
if it did what you asked it yeah so it
inside this query I've buried the
request for the server to sleep for two
seconds there's two hammers which
basically means to every row but it
finds it's also going to wait two
seconds which is two okay four seconds
now MySQL has a sleep function in it
cattle eight asleep brackets the number
of seconds you want to sleep for its
wait for delay in SQL Server so I would
adjust this slightly and I try again so
if it didn't sleep I think I probably
not SQL MySQL maybe I'll try the
equivalent for Postgres or try be
equivalent there are what we call blind
SQL injections where even if we're not
getting any output we can base it on
just a time it takes to respond work out
what's going on you could do another
thing where you said select from a
certain table name and also sleep and if
it comes back slowly you know at the
table with that name okay so you can
even if there's no output use this blind
technique to work out what's going on
okay it's going to take you a little
while to do right in my case I happen to
get it the first time yay okay so good
news right so now what can we do so
let's start with my hammer thing again
so I'm going to take this I'm going to
copy it okay next up we're going to use
the fact that we know it's MySQL to try
and find some more information on what
tables exists and so on this isn't a
blind SQL injection because if I search
a hammer it produces me a table so it's
actually outputting to the screen now
this is very common a shop you search
for product it's got to take that table
information and turn it into an HTML
format for you to look at okay so even
if it doesn't look like an actual table
like on my bad website it is in a sense
that if taken table data have turned
into some form so it will event also
downloaded a picture of the product you
know
some reviews I'll get rid of this bit
this sleep and I say what can I do that
sticks information I'd like to extract
from database on the end of this product
so what I really want to do is turn this
table into a table that dumps out you
know passwords or something like that if
such things exist in this database now
in SQL we use the Union keyword to do
this okay so Union basically takes two
tables with the same amount of columns
and sticks and one on top of the other
so if I can find a way of sticking some
personal private database information on
the bottom of the camera list then it's
going to output it to the screen so
select something from some table now all
we know about this miss select is what
it's selecting three columns okay
because it's three columns output at
least that's what I'm hypothesizing so
select three columns from some table
where some column name is like hammer
okay so what I'm going to do instead is
I'm going to say like hammer
Union sub query select one two three
from jewel now for those of you don't
know my spiel particularly jewel is
essentially a placeholder table name to
select from if you don't really have a
table to select for okay it's use for
testing purposes mostly okay
so I'm literally selecting the numbers 1
2 & 3 in three columns from some
hypothetical jewel table right now if
this works what it will do is stick one
two three on a row or the bottom of my
hammers if it works okay so let's see so
take my hammer I copy all the way to the
end there we go and I go into my website
and I search and there's my one two
three okay that's bad news for the event
with this website which coincidentally
is me okay so the fact that I can output
queries to the screen is really bad it's
not just bad it's catastrophic
okay because we're only a few steps away
from full-on users and passwords so
let's do it so yeah not to be too
cavalier about the security right so
let's not select one two and free from
jewel because maybe that's not very
informative okay let's select from MySQL
information schema so there's a table in
the information schema called funnily
enough information T its key médoc
tables and that will tell us all the
table information names of tables what
columns they have and so on it's the
table of tables takes the table tables
right let's
Union select table name table schema
which is the database name and then a
three because we need to make sure the
number of columns match up between our
Union table and the original hammer
table does it just put it underneath it
literally just pay put it underneath yet
if you want to merge columns it sort of
it row by row that's a join and if
you're just sticking on top of us that's
an appending that's a Union just just
two different terms for sq up so select
table name table scheme work three from
information schema dot tables notice
it's got purple which is a good sign
because it means that this syntax
highlighting recognizes I vouch typed in
an SQL come on so let's copy this the
slow way with my fingers there we go and
paste that in there there we go so the
information schema is essentially a
metadata table but holds information on
all the columns and tables and number of
rows and things for all the tables you
would query if you want to know what
columns exist and what tables exist I've
got a claw hammer and I've got a
sledgehammer I've got a funny blog table
called evil and a funny blog table
called posts which we may talk about in
a different video right I haven't
bothered to put them in different
databases that's with honet right then
we have a bunch of kind of almost semi
random tables this is MySQL stuff we
scroll down and then right at the bottom
we've got the shop tables and we've got
a table called stock and a table called
users so we won't select anything from
stock because I doesn't seems very
interesting particular as we can search
for anyway but we use this table on your
hand might seem quite useful to us okay
we don't know what's in there but we've
got to assume some kind of user data now
if we go back to my SQL query we know
what the table is what we don't know is
what the columns are in the table and if
we want to put some output from that
users table on the bottom of our table
we're going to need to know what the
column names are cuz otherwise we can't
select them we can't just say select
everything because they'll probably be
more than three columns and that won't
union properly so we're going to say
select something like hammer Union
select column name two three from
information schema
I'm off screen now let's keep scrolling
info schema dot-coms where table name so
the information schema doc columns table
unsurprisingly has column information
also has what table that column belongs
to my table name equals users okay
well I thought about that there we go
okay that looks good to me so let's copy
that let's see if it works there we go
okay so what we've got is we've got our
hammers again alright we're going to
keep seeing them and then we've got a
couple of standard MySQL things like
current connections how many people are
logged in and then we've got some actual
column names user ID user login user
hash user type now anyone that knows
anything about hashing passwords and so
on nut can guess that the ID is probably
just for not a number representing that
user probably just stuck in the table by
default the login is going to be their
login name and hash is going to be a
hashed version of their password okay
now most database cracks don't get
unencrypted passwords people are slowly
at least wiring up a little bit to
hashing although they don't tend to hash
them particularly securely so this is
this is certainly a candidate for crack
path of cracking for example so let's
get those things out so we need three
columns from the users table and we want
all of it right so we want let's say
user login user hash and user type so
let's get rid of this select here we go
and we've owner so we're still unioning
that's I don't know if that's an actual
verb we're still performing a union
Select you name is it you name or is it
you login you login okay so you you
login you hash you type from users and
that's all three columns append it to
the previous one any so we'll copy that
and see if it works and it does so we've
got a bunch of users they're hashed
passwords and we also see but because of
a type this guy's an admin okay so I
would focus on his password personally
right so that's pretty scary okay it
didn't take me very many queries to get
through this now before everyone goes
off and cracks these passwords right
what you're welcome to do if you want
but bear in mind this is a website that
only runs on my computer and these are
probably just the word password or
something like that because I wasn't
being particularly careful when I
created this database these aren't real
people whose password you're cracking
here so don't waste your time
I advise it's scary how easy that how
easy that was to do now Tom talks a lot
about how you stop this kind of stuff
from happening
okay parameterize queries sanitizing an
input so but I can't put single quotes
in without them being escaped okay
those sort of things are important but
you have to also think about things like
second order SQL injections which is
where I put something into an SQL Server
and then it gets used internally as a
query so for example I make my username
a SQL injection right and it gets
escaped properly but it gets stored in
the database and then when I go to
change my password the injection gets
run okay so that's a second-order
injection so there's loads of
complicated stuff you can do that could
get around some of these things so if
you're a web developer you have to pay a
lot of attention to this because you
don't want your users hashed passwords
and email address combinations stuck on
the net because it's embarrassing and
illegal and really bad news for your
customers
I mean case in point talk talk got
hacked a few months ago and that was
hacked by essentially a script a Python
script that performs what I just did but
in bulk really really quickly it takes
I've run it it takes about on my website
free commands to obtain what I just
obtained and dump them to a file which
is pretty terrifying you know so I would
suggest people start scientists
analyzing their inputs pretty quick
is that if I obtain a cookie of you
which is supposed to be secure then I
can send that to let's say Amazon or to
a shop and say I'm Sean please you know
what's in the shopping basket what's his
address
what's his credit card details